well guys it happened G2 finally finally
won a CS go tournament after five years
of sweeps shuffles and well whiffs this
ill-fated super team has broken the
curse adding a tier one trophy to their
collection for the first time since
2017.
and I mean
what a way to do it like just
no works so obviously I would wish that
my father could see that I actually
accomplished something I think he would
be proud of me for once
okay so anyone who knows CS go knows
that G2 has been a notoriously coin
flippy Powerhouse for what feels like
forever the thing is in terms of when
they actually last won something it's
sort of actually has been
forever prior to the blast World final
the last time that G2 won a tier 1
International land was dreamhack Malmo
2017. that was over half a decade ago
which is half the lifespan of
Counter-Strike Global Offensive to put
it simply G2 has been perpetually down
bad the last time G2 won a trophy Apex
was still on the team and scream had
only left like six months prior to say
it was a different time would be an
understatement it was a different era
since then they've gone International
bench Kenny gotten Nico got swept by
simple in like three finals bought
monacy picked up xdq and Alexi kicked
xtq and Alexi snagged jks in this Giga
chat named hooksy and failed to qualify
for a major after getting smoked by
gamer Legion is that it point is heading
into the blast Global final G2 are
basically the biggest disaster in a
professional Counter-Strike a
spectacularly stacked disaster who I've
always said has a [__] ton of potential
but a disaster nonetheless do you
understand that the last time that Nico
arguably the best rifler alive what a CS
go land was at blast Miami three and a
half years ago like do you understand
how insane that is and yes I recognize
that some of that did have to do with
the online era but still it's sort of
ridiculous that you could be a
consistent top three player globally and
just casually go almost four years
without winning a single tournament
suffice it to say going into the blast
World final which took place last
weekend nobody was really expecting much
from G2 it was the last tournament of
the year they had only gotten sixth at
the fall finals and let's be honest
after the major bomb out their roster
was sort of a question mark the thing is
all of this was instantly overshadowed
by the deeply tragic news that hoopsy
received not one day after arriving at
the tournament according to a twitlonger
published on the morning of December
13th hoaxi was informed shortly after
landing that his father had passed away
suddenly and unexpectedly the day prior
he made it clear that he'd opted to play
the tournament because it abided with
his family's wishes and that he hoped it
would serve as a distraction of sorts
given that hooksy is the team's igl and
that his mind might very understandably
be elsewhere
I think it's fair to say that everyone
was prepared to give G2 a pass on this
one some things are more important in
life than winning indeed more important
than Counter-Strike and yet despite
finishing third in their group when it
came time to drop the gloves against
Vitality G2 shocked everyone lays down
the incendiary looks away dies at the
hands of Nico now do three also dead and
G2 believe your eyes where they've
already shown us greatness and Hunter
will not let this chance slide through
their fingertips Vitality thought they
would have this but a CT side that has
fallen flat zaiwu 15 health and
montessor ready to put the nail in the
coffin
they lean back and with that off they'll
collect their kills their 16th round and
their second map in this series and man
was hoopsy's calling on point like their
t-sides were super crisp and they were
playing with a supreme level of
confidence the thing is going into their
semi-final bout against FaZe it wasn't
apparent how far that would actually
carry until they started playing it
wasn't just that G2 were confident they
were charismatic they were having fun
and while both Maps were definitely
squeakers whose Squad just found that
extra gear and did what no one thought
they could modesty so close his
teammates lean back because they're not
even
G2 will end this year where they started
it a grand finals but this is hooksies
G2 hooksy
you've done it your first ever tier one
Grand Final awaits tomorrow what does
this feel like
ah it's pretty crazy honestly also the
movie one life really felt like it was a
tough first half like a lot of mistakes
is also for me individually so I'm also
proud of myself that I actually stepped
up and could actually call a good
Seaside even though I had a really bad
individual game so okay now I know what
all of you you scrub muffins are
thinking a grand final against chokewood
easy for hooksy and like look I get it
the proof is in the pudding but I do
think it is fair to say that heading
into this Grand Final liquid were
favorites who see
just didn't give it limited yeah they
got all the needs they want hoaxy on a
worse gun still for AKs is better than
most of these rounds oh called out wow
doesn't need to see him doesn't need to
shoot him artillery barrage top mid but
it's a big one wait what are they doing
doubling back again
Alicia's gonna go try to stuff him and
bottom mid and instead Nico gets the
head oh what make it a double they're
making it up as they go
Nitro really do the unthinkable at this
point
G2 decide to Sprint away and to their
success I mean listen for a second it
looks sketchy but his rotations are
actually unreal and while the kovatch's
watch is on guess what
two brothers from Bosnia with a
childhood dream to win events since this
all started
and ladies and gentlemen believe your
eyes
with the newest Champions
G2 do the unthinkable
1092 days since G2 took a map in a grand
final and these go in for the sweep I
was sad to see liquid lose of course but
how could I be upset over such a
harrowing heartfelt victory for not only
of roster who needed it but a player
well I think it's obvious what I what
I'm going to say next I'm not going to
stand here being cry baby because I've
been crying for a week straight but
obviously I would wish that my father
would see that I actually accomplished
something I think he would be proud of
me for once and
I think we're all very proud of you for
those who aren't up to date on hooksy's
miraculous meme filled journey into the
upper echelon a professional
Counter-Strike you're in luck we did a
video on it so check it out learn how
and why this unproven still burgeoning
shot caller was put in charge of csgo's
coin flippiest super team and how him
being a giga Chad went from a
community-wide roast to a reality hooksy
in the face of adversity and critique
you have facilitated g2's first trophy
lift since
2017. how do you feel about that
uh in case you're sorry for my language
but I don't know again now I said on
stage that I didn't want to be a cry
baby I can tell you I've been a crybaby
for the last six months the first
I think the second day at boot camp with
D2 when I joined the team I was sitting
in my hotel room crying because my
father wasn't good enough and now I'm
standing here with the trophy in my
hands and I don't know what to tell you
I honestly don't know what to say anyway
on the whole an amazing amazing event
obviously it was nice to see Nico and
his drought and win with Hunter and
monacy pick up his first big trophy and
MVP and watch jks both start and end the
year with a big event win what the
spells for g2's future is sort of hard
to say since this team does like to be
unpredictable what's certain is that it
has taken the pressure off and shown
that their potential can be realized
let's just hope we don't have to wait
another five years to see it realized
since then they've okay so how the [__]
we're gonna do this God need no bench
gotten Sweat by simply like three finals
benched Kenny
snagged no it was the next one gotta
stop by simple since then they've gone
International benched Kenny gotten Nico
bought Monastery gotten swapped
snagged jks on this good